Uh it is my honor to uh introduce our
next speaker uh from Hitachi. It is Uta
Yajimasan. So thank you for joining us.
Um uh they bring or he brings um deep
expertise in network coding and AIdriven
solutions. Uh Yajima focuses on
developing innovative technologies. uh
today he's going to spot talk about and
explore how leveraging graph structures
and generative AI can transform decision
making and business processes. So please
join me in welcoming Yajimasan. Thank
you for joining us.
[applause]
>> Thank you for the introduction.
I will start my presentation. Let me
start by introducing the speakers. I'm
Uajima.
Uh I'm I'm uh research I'm part of
research and development group at
Shidaji and belong to advanced
artificial intelligence
innovation center. This presentation was
uh prepared by myself and Mr. Matsumoto
and Mr. harder and I will give
presentation today.
Uh our main research topics are
operational analysis using GPS and
sensor data data analytics to improve
customers business graph neural networks
and generative AI.
Hitachi is one of Japan's leading
companies operating globally a wide
range of business sectors.
This right shows range of this this
shows four main business sectors of our
organization.
Power and energy sector, industry
distribution, water sector, urban sector
and finance, social and healthcare
sector.
Notably, Hitachi has worldrenowned
technology in the railway sector.
In the UK, for instance, Hitachi trains
are used on two routes connecting London
with northern and western part of the
country as part of the IEP.
Hitachi's business is broadly divided
into three business domains.
Uh digital systems and services,
connective industries and green energy
and mobility.
A notable feature of Hitachi is that
many of these businesses include OT. OT
is operational technology.
OT involves hardware and software
technologies for monitoring and
controlling physical devices and
processes.
Next, this slide shows Hitachi's
revenues by region. Hitachi operates
business businesses worldwide and has
different business portfolios for each
region.
What I want notice here is that Japan's
ratio is 41%.
This means that overseas revenues are
higher.
It is clear that Hitachi is not just a
Japanese company but is engaged in a
wide range of businesses globally.
This shows market trend of generative
AI.
First please focus on situation
surrounding generative AI.
The growth rate C AGR of generative AI
market is very high.
which shows how much attention
generative AI is received
and how rapidly it is expanding.
Oh, I I also want touch on investment
trends. Many investments are being made
in startups related to generative AI.
These investments are further driving
market expansion.
Next, please focus on classification of
how AI is leveraged.
Microsoft classifies the use of
generative AI into four categories.
Reshaping business process, enriching
employee experiences,
bending the curve on innovation and
reinventing customer engagement.
We are particularly focusing on
reshaping business process.
We are going to transform the business
process in the following manner using
generative AI
in management. Our challenge is adapting
to dynamic business environment
by combining generative AI with
enterprise AI
on GMA. Uh our challenge is improving
productivity and wellbeing of frontline
workers
by combining generative AI with
industrial AI.
Instead of instead of considering the
knowledge from management to gamba
separately,
we we promote nar saturation by
accumulating and sharing it thus driving
business transformation.
This is today's talk. First framework
enabling datadriven
decision making.
Second of how we are trying to apply
past success stories to new business.
Finally, applications have been re
framework that realized this and their
effect.
This shows challenge we are working on.
We are attempting to drive business
transformation by combining AI with game
knowledge.
However, there is often a gap between
managers and game staff.
This is leading to a lack of consensus
between the two
which frequently poses a problem.
Bes
survey reveals that 60% of managers
believe that they need to improve their
KPIs
but only 34%
are using AI to create new KPIs
and this is that uh incentive structure
is in line with objectives
about five times more than at
organizations that do not use AI to
create new KPIs
and increased collaboration between
employees
about four times more than at
organizations that do not use AI to
create new KPIs.
To address our challenge, we have
developed
um information organization framework.
We organize each project systematically
by four tasks.
First or task one is stakeholder
analysis.
Using this we understand the flow of
value among stakeholders
which is important for sales expansion
and horizontal development of
projects.
Task two is challenge identification.
[clears throat]
Using this we set a goal based on cause
and effect of customer business
challenges and measures
which are important to verify the
effectiveness of tackling each
challenge.
Task three is factor identification.
We assess of constraints in business
processes and operations important for
delivery and effective measures to be
taken in the short term.
Task four is meology design.
Using this we select appropriate method
based on the types of tasks and
constraints important for systemization
and
implementation.
Let me show each graph of the framework.
This is task one graph.
Using this we check key entities and
business structure
for example
experts within the company and
stakeholders beyond the customers.
This is task two graph. Using this we
check overall picture of challenges and
challenges to focus on.
For example,
connection to management challenges
and priority of challenges.
This is task three graph. Using this we
check business process and available
data.
For example,
where improvements can be made
and other is to be comparison.
This is task four graph.
Using this we check technological
approaches and procedures.
For example, differences in approach and
data consideration.
We utilize this framework in real
project.
Let me show analysis results on
challenge expansion
extraction.
We propose ideas to assume multiple
challenges from the perspectives of
people, goods and environment and draw
out strategy images
and gradually guide from visualizing
delivery actions to proposing measures
for the higher goal of oper operational
efficiency
and the visibility. of anious objectives
linked to business challenges allowed
for personalization and agreement with
the customer.
The framework is not something that is
used just once and then finished.
The structure of data created using this
framework grows together with a
customer.
We will discover new challenges in line
with a customer's business growth and
draw up a scenario for pivoting on
target challenges.
For example, even if a graph of
inial graph has only economic value,
we can add social value,
governance value and environmental
value.
We are accelerating the development of
the framework by reverting generative
AI.
This diagram show shows an overview.
Users create unstructured data through
the ex externalization
by documentation
from this unstructured data. Extraction
and structuring are performed to create
structured data.
We have developed an application that
automates this process.
Then users provide feedback on the
structured data
enhancing its quality.
We believe that structuring and refining
knowledge through a human in the room
approach is important.
First let me show this application one.
The highlighted part of the diagram is
related to it.
Application one is automatic generation
of challenge graphs.
There is a difficulty in understanding
customer strategies.
It is difficult to extract customer
challenges because IR documents are
effective information sources
but they require readings through
hundreds of pages
and because skills are needed to
determine whether the information is
related to the challenges.
It is also difficult to organize
extracted ones
because include IR document include v
various layers of information from
management challenges to gamber ones.
To solve this, we utilize LM for
extracting information related to
customer wants
and summarizing and structuring
extracted ones.
This is application one's input and
output.
We input company information. For
example, company name is Hitachi.
Document type is IR in 2023.
Input language and output language is
English.
And then
application output structured graph like
this.
Next, let me explain the application
concerning the interaction between users
and structured data.
The highlighted part of the diagram is
related to there.
Application two is graph review
assistance.
There is an issue of automatically
created graph
in in automatic generation tools.
Graphs are structured from IR.
I often include management challenges
but frequently rack gamble ones.
So it is necessary to supplement them.
To solve this uh application to
recommend rated nodes from accumulated
positive graphs.
First we select a node of the graph
and relevant nodes are recommended from
the accumulated graph of the path.
Refer one is recommended nodes
and also node seleed by the user to the
graph.
Application three is solution design.
There are issues in sales activities.
It is difficult to
identify appropriate solutions for
customer business transformation
challenges
and it is also difficult to understand
the explain effect and various
solutions.
To solve this
application three, structure and
organize the challenges addressed by
solutions from solution explanation
materials
and use graph neural networks to suggest
solutions with a high potential match to
customers.
Next application four is no scoring
to identify the challenges to address.
Priority scores for challenges can be
automatically calculated based on a
small amount of input.
of clicking on each node opens a weight
adjustment dialogue
or
reset scores of some node.
Based on the scores assigned to the some
nodes, the GN predict the scores for all
nodes
and the color changes according to the
weight.
This scoring makes the importance of
challenges visually clear and can
support deciding which challenges to
tackle.
We had people try out the framework and
received feedback.
Their aim is ger and analyze factbased
information on understand outstanding
business solutions from leading global
companies across various industries.
To do this, seate information from 240
companies.
go through hundreds pages of annual
report or an integrated report and pick
up key points on organiz
240 hours without using the application
were reduced to 40 hours
allowing the saved time to be used for
reflection.
and idea generation.
This slide shows their ideas for
utilizing the framework.
This set quickly discover discover
something new from macro and micro
perspective and use it to strengthen
organizational intelligence.
First idea is deep understanding of
industry trends for client companies.
Users notice such challenges such
changes have occurred over the past year
based on documents from multiple
companies over multiple years.
Second idea is explor exploration of new
solution. Seems
users notice that what such technology
or solutions based on documents from
overseas and emerging publicity
publicly research companies.
Third idea is deepen understanding of
client companies business challenges.
Users notice that there are challenges
that have
persist that have persisted for a long
time based on documents from client
companies spanning multiple years.
A Rust or Rust idea is analysis of
competitive trends.
Users notice that this is what they are
doing recently
based on documents from competitor
companies.
This is summary.
We introduced a graph-based information
organization framework to enable
datadriven decision making
and developed applications on the
framework to the help to the help make
use of the framework and apply past
success stories to new business using LM
and GNN.
A trial showed more than significant
time savings.
We we are developing applications so
ideas on other application are very
welcome.
Thank you.
>> Awesome. So we have uh just a few
minutes for questions if anybody has uh
specific questions for Eugene.
[laughter]
All right. So, I will uh so thank you
again and please find him uh in the
networking or uh pull him aside uh and
ask any questions you you may have.